What's this about today. So I wanted to talk about a paper should just come out.
It's entitled gravitational wave constraints on the equatorial Ellipta city of
millisecond pulsars the front page of it,
as well as the title is basically all authors. And in fact,
if I turn to the second page, that's all authors too.
And if I turn to the third page, that's all authors. Wow.
The reason why it's so many authors is because it's one of the papers from LIGO
and Virgo. So the gravitational wave detection consortium,
and actually this is about not detecting gravitational waves and it turns out
sometimes not detecting gravitational waves is as interesting as detecting them.
They're looking at neutron stars pulse.
So these are these very compact stellar remnants where the whole massive star up
to a couple of solar masses is pressed down into a region about 20 kilometers
across so tiny little objects that are leftover when stars blow up.
Professor,
is there a difference between a neutron star and a pollster are all neutron
stars, also a upholster.
So all pulsars are neutron stars, but not all neutron stars are Paul Saul.
So Paul saws are the ones we can see.
And the reason why we can see them is because these objects are rotating
generally quite fast. They have a magnetic field.
If that made me feel this sort of misaligned with the rotation,
then you get basically a lighthouse effect.
You have the light that's being produced along the magnetic field lines through
a process called synchrotron. And as the thing spins around,
you basically see the flashes of light as it goes past.
And so that's how they were first detected by Jocelyn bell Burnell,
where she detected these very regular pulses,
which are from these flashes of light as the neutron stars rotating.
If it turns out that the lighthouse beam happens not to be pointed in our
direction, then we won't see it.
And so basically this there'll be a neutron star,
but we won't see it as a Pulser. But anyway,
some of them are pulsars and they're spinning some of them very fast.
Some of them, a thousand times a second,
the things called millisecond pulse horse. I mean, they are mind blowing things,
right?
You've got several times the mass of the sun squashed down into a region 20
kilometers across rotating up to a thousand times a second,
quite phenomenal objects.
But one consequence of that is that you might expect them to radiate
gravitational waves. Now, if they're exactly symmetrical, they won't.
Because if you think about it, if you had something,
which is actually just kind of completely say it was feral,
or even it was somewhat flattened. If it's not actually sort of,
if it's just rotating around that axis,
then the shape doesn't change at all in the, in three dimensions,
it just kind of rotates around, which means that the gravitational field,
the things producing really doesn't change either.
Whereas if it were kind of very lopsided,
as it rotated around the shape would kind of change in the sky,
which means its gravitational field would change.
And one of the consequences of that is that it within radiate gravitational
waves, you can calculate, well,
how much by where gravitational waves would it radiate?
The answer is not a huge amount.
It's nothing like the things that they'd been detecting with LIGO. Like,
you know,
these merging neutron stars and black holes and things which produce these
enormous bursts of gravitational waves, you might think, well, you know,
they can only just detect these much more spectacular events.
How could they hope to detect one of these neutron stars?
The answer is they know where to look because we know exactly what the period of
rotation of these things are. Cause if it's a,
Pulser just measure the time between the pulses. And so for example,
the crab pulse all goes round 30 times a second, 30 Hertz. And from that,
and it turns out the gravitational waves are radiated at twice the frequency of
the rotation period. So inconveniently, it would actually be 60 Hertz,
which is the electricity frequency of a fair part of the world,
which turns out to be a major source of interference.
So you can't actually detect it or it's very hard to detect the craft balsa,
but other pulsars have less inconvenient frequencies that they're rotating it.
So then you know exactly what frequency you look at.
You can just kind of add up all the data and just search at that one frequency
to say, is there anything going on?
If I combine all the data together at that one frequency,
it's a little bit more complicated because it could be, for example,
if the thing really worth slightly lopsided,
it might be kind of processing around as well as rotating.
We've changed the frequency a little bit. It could be that the interior,
the neutron star is actually rotating at a slightly different speed from the
exterior. It could be kind of slushy and around faster in the interior,
which again would change the frequency of it.
So you have to search around a little bit infrequency, but you know,
pretty much exactly where to look. So they looked in all these places.
They've now got lots of data from Lego,
from Virgo that they they're able to look to see if there are any emissions from
these neutron stars. The answer is there isn't any,
they were able to put really strong upper limits on how much gravitational waves
there are.
And hence indirectly that tells you how isometric the pulse all is allowed to
be. And the answer is absolutely tiny, right?
It turns out if you wanted to make a pulse saw lopsided if you made it lopsided.
So I suppose if you had an exactly spherical neutron star, 20 kilometers across,
if you distorted one side of it, literally by a hair's breadth.
So by the width of a human hair,
that would create enough asymmetry that with the sensitivity they had,
they'd have been able to detect it. Huh? So they know to,
within a hair's breadth, these neutron stars have to be exactly symmetric.
So professor, I presume they looked at a few neutron stars,
not just one there's about half a dozen, maybe in this one.
The thing I was thinking when you first started telling me about this was surely
something spinning that fast.
I would have thought maybe there'll be something about that process that would
make it symmetrical. And the fact that all of them are symmetrical. I mean,
is it a cause or an effect I guess is what I'm saying?
It's a con I mean, I think even if they weren't spinning,
they'd still end up very symmetrical because the pool of that, I mean,
they're basically held together by nuclear forces, right?
And those sorts of forces are so strong that they will actually pull everything
in, in a very symmetric fashion, but being able to measure it, you know,
to within a hair's breadth for a pulse on it really shows quite how amazingly
symmetric, they really are.
Another way of saying this is that they would have a very smooth surface or
yeah.
Absolutely. And you know, smoother than the proverbial baby's bottom,
they really are. It has to be absolutely smooth because any little ripples, the,
where will create those kinds of asymmetries that they'd be able to detect in
gravitational waves smoother.
Than a billiard ball.
Way, way, way smoother than a billionaire.
Can we make things that smooth is this smoother than humans can make? Or,
you know, you hear things about these, you know,
these spheres of Silicon and stuff like that. And.
That's a very good question. I honestly don't know.
I'd have to do the calculation to see. Yeah. I mean, when the,
one of the things,
when they were thinking about redefining the kilogram was about making
incredibly smooth spheres of select Silicon to within kind of a single atom.
And I'd have to do the calculation to figure out whether or not this is smoother
than that. But I wouldn't be surprised if it was cause it, you know, here,
we're talking about 20 kilometers across on a hair's breadth.
So it's really is a tiny perturbation.
Are we talking about when we say smooth for something that's not really matter
though, is that we say are smoother than a billiard ball,
but it's this isn't made of matter as we know it is, or.
Yeah. Kind of, I mean, it's made of neutrons mostly, at least it's out.
What does it, if I know, I know there'll be a lot of problems.
If I went close to a neutron star and tried to touch it, I'm not naive to that,
but if I did touch it, what am I touching? Is it, is that hard? Is it cold?
Is it hot? Like what does it compare to.
Just above the surface of the neutron star is its atmosphere,
which again is tiny,
but there are energetic electrons and so on in the immediate vicinity of it.
So you will probably be able to touch those. But I honestly don't know,
is this your answer? Um, but apart from the fact that I wouldn't recommend it,
but beyond that, I really don't know how,
what you would actually feel if you were able to stroke a neutron star.
And I put that on my bucket list. I guess.
Another thing to say about it,
which is that there was already a constraint on how smooth these things were,
which comes from the fact that if they were somewhat asymmetric and they were
giving out these gravitational waves, but energy has to come from somewhere.
And the answer is, it comes from the spin of the neutron star.
And so what you would expect is that if it were radiating these gravitational
waves away through these kinds of asymmetries, the neutron star should do,
what's known as spinning down. It should slow down,
but that comes back to probably two, um, the, the pulse or effect again,
remember I said that if there's a magnetic field,
which is a bit misaligned with the rotation, you'll see these pulses.
One of the other things of having the magnetic field kind of spinning around
like that is that in itself produces electromagnetic waves,
which also carry away energy.
So some of the energy being carried away from a neutron star causing it to spin
down, comes from this, what's called magnetic dipole radiation.
The fact that you've got these spinning magnet,
the most conservative thing you can say is, well,
let's presume pre pretend that that's not there at all.
Maybe if the entire spin down, we're just coming from gravitational waves.
What would that mean for the asymmetry of the neutron star?
And it turns out that already gives you a quite interesting limit on how smooth
the neutron star has to be.
What's new about this result is this is the first time they've gone beyond that
limit to actually measure effectively a limit on the gravitational waves
themselves rather than from this indirect effect.
Tell you what black holes get all the good publicity and the glamour.
But I think neutron stars are awesome.
At least they can do stuff, right?
A black hole is just black and there's not much you can say about it.
Interesting things go on around it. But neutron stars,
you can actually say interesting things about the neutron star itself.
That's 142 is out here. They found a bump.
They found an increase in the number of, uh,
electron positron pairs coming out.
You have a melting temperature of about 25,000 Kelvin,
which is kind of your typical temperature of a lightning bolt and the specific
heat capacity of water.